one of the more interesting characters
in the recent video game Assassin's
Creed Mirage is the poet arib who shows
up throughout the story and whose
affiliations with the conspiratory
forces are a bit
unclear arib is indeed another one of
those characters that are based on a
real historical figure and her life can
tell us a lot about Society music and
art in the abased caliphate during the
so-called Islamic golden age AR al-
munia was a famous singer and poet that
grew up in the Abbasid Heartland of
Bagdad and was possibly a Persian origin
as some stories claim that she was the
daughter of the famous jaffar the bakid
she belonged to the class or group of
women called the Kanan who were
essentially slave girls that were
professional musicians and singers this
was an important institution in aasad
society and these slave women played a
major role especially in the musical
life of the Islamic world this is also
why some Muslim clerics were skeptical
of Music at the time music was almost
exclusively associated with slave girls
alcohol and erotic promiscuity but
regardless of all this music and these
singing girls thean played a major role
across the Islamic world at this time
and especially in the Khalifa Heartland
of Bagdad and among all these singing
girls arib is perhaps the most famous we
get most of our information about her
from what is probably the most important
book on early
arabicislamic music and music Traditions
theab or book of songs by AB far alwi
alahani which cataloges thousands of
songs poems and tells stories about
famous composers musicians and
performers from pre-islamic Arabia all
the way up to the 10th century when Abul
faraj actually wrote and in this work we
are told that arib was a prominent
concubine of several Abbasid calebs in
including al- Amin and al- the two sons
of harun Rashid that fought a bloody
Civil War for the
throne she was eventually set free by
al- successor al- MIM but continued her
career as one of the most loved
musicians and singers in Bagdad at the
time becoming quite wealthy and Powerful
while still serving as musical performer
and possibly lover of future cffs as
well in the society musical Gatherings
were basically everywhere in the cifal
courts in taverns and private house
Gatherings or meles and in the religious
gatherings of the sufis and with the
probably exception of the last category
women like Ari played an important role
in these context she would have
performed at such Gatherings both
private and public she said to have had
a beautiful voice and to have mastered
the instrument known as the OD or loot
with which he would accompany her
singing being a musician at this time as
especially as prominent as her required
an immense amount of learning and
knowledge it would often be expected to
know any possible song that a patron
could spontaneously request and to be
able to improvise and adjust the
performance according to the audience
and context which in itself required
deep knowledge of music theory in terms
of the different modes patterns and
rhythms that made up the musical system
at that time for this reason there
existed prominent schools of Music at
this time one in Bagdad associated with
people like ibraim and isak
and which AR would have been a part of
there was also one school in Medina
which also had a vibrant music scene and
eventually one all the way over in
Cordoba established by the famous zirab
music was also strongly and almost
necessarily connected with poetry at
this time the line between poetic
recitation and singing was obviously
very blurry and musical accompaniment
often had the express purpose of
enhancing vocal singing and recitation
or as instrumental preludes to a song it
isn't surprising therefore that arib was
also a prominent and celebrated poet and
would perform those poems in different
Gatherings a truly remarkable woman in
many ways of whom One account says quote
I never saw a more beautiful or refined
woman than arib nor one who sang played
music wrote poetry or played chess so
well once a slave arib used her skills
as a musician performer and poet to rise
in rank at the abased courts eventually
through these efforts being set free and
establishing herself as one of the most
famous powerful and Wealthy women in 9th
century
bad after a long and prosperous life she
is reported to have died in her 99s
around the year 891 having lived through
some of the most tumultuous events in
Middle Eastern history seing the rise
and fall of the abasa Dynasty and
foundational developments in the Islamic
religion in this incredibly eventful
time it's quite remarkable that a slave
woman and musician still managed to make
such a Mark that we still remember her
over a thousand years later and the fact
that Assassin's Creed Mirage includes
her as a prominent character make sure
that that Memory Remains and is
strengthened giving us a fasting and
glimpse into society music performance
and courtly life in the so-called golden
age of
[Music]
Islam
n